at the end of the day mended fences
between ea and colin kaepernick they
worked out a deal to put him back in the
game and chris this is significant for a
couple of reasons first of all there's
no way in hell ea is going rogue here
and doing this deal without the approval
of the nfl
exclusively nfl licensed video game
right you are not even though they just
signed a new contract you are not going
to gratuitously piss off your 25-year
partner over something like this you
talk to them before you do it you get
their agreement before you do it and
there's got to be a story behind the
story as to who went to whom whose idea
was it how did this ball get rolling to
put colin kaepernick back in this game
at a time when no one wants to put him
back in the nfl it really was stunning
that that dropped out of the blue
yesterday afternoon
and the folks at ea
all of a sudden have a high opinion of
the guy chris he's an 81 overall rating
we're going to talk more about how that
compares to other quarterbacks but 81 is
pretty good and they view him as a
starting caliber quarterback even though
he's been out for three years and this
is the official nfl video game that's
saying this at a time when none of the
32 teams will give him
any type of serious consideration it's
really a stunning disconnect between
what the people at ea think and what the
32 teams think yeah well okay so there's
a lot first off it's awesome i'm glad
colin kaepernick's back in the game just
to take a positive route here i mean
yeah i mean he's
he's
of course sacrificed a lot certainly i
mean he did he did he gave up his career
to fight for an issue that is way bigger
than his career and of course has a huge
a huge topic here in our country you
know but as far as like
where he's rated and things like that i
i gotta i can't lie it bothers me a
little bit like do you want to start you
want to talk about like the quarterbacks
that he's raided in front of first you
want to list them off because honestly i
think it's disrespectful to a lot of
guys that played in football yeah there
you go i like colin kaepernick and if
anybody has listened to me over the last
four years the first year he was out of
football i said he was better than at
least 16 17 starting quarterbacks and
the second year he was out of football
you know i yep he's still worthy of
being in the starting quarterback
conversation you know maybe a high level
backup but to say that he is a better
overall rating and he hasn't played
football and we're getting here to four
years then guys like ryan tannehill who
were just absolutely awesome last year
or cam newton who
you know
has been an mvp of football and is
healthy again or
a jared goff who's been into the super
bowl i think there's a number of names
on this list where i look at it and i
just go i think that's absolutely
ludicrous to say that he's better than
those football players when he hasn't
played football and that long of a time
i'm cool with it great he's in the game
but that's that's just stupid to me i
don't even know what else to say
same rating as ben roethlisberger you
mean the guy who throw for 5 000 yards
two years ago and like almost 40
touchdowns and was the highest fantasy
quarterback there was we're gonna say
he's the same as him right now that that
to me no no dice
one spot behind kirk cousins and philip
rivers as well and and look
these numbers are by no means set in
stone but it it just shows that the
video game that is connected to the
national football league has all of a
sudden had a dramatic change of heart
and and they've got now now look here's
here's the thing
there's some interesting issues of
timing here as it relates to colin
kaepernick being added to the game right
after
well i've got i've got two takes i
raised one yesterday the other one just
occurred to me
um i
if you announce in advance of the
release of the game that colin
kaepernick is going to be in the game
you're probably going to get a boycott
you're going to get a backlash but now
everyone's bought it i'd say 95 of the
people who were going to buy madden have
bought madden the dust is settled what
are you going to do return it no you
can't it's too late you've already
bought it i never thought of that do
about it yeah well i just thought of
that now because we haven't heard any
real pushback against ea one of the
reasons these teams won't sign colin
kaepernick or even talk to colin
kaepernick is they don't want to deal
with the pr hit right of dealing with
colin kaepernick this reviled figure by
30 of the country and ea hasn't hit that
yet but they've already made their major
sell they've already had the downloads
the people have the game
and they can say oh we're not going to
buy it next year by next year they'll
forget about it so i think that waiting
until yesterday
for a business reason from ea's
perspective makes sense yeah i get that
that does make sense you're right i
never thought about it but yes
you got the people you got the money
they paid for it oh okay now hey there's
a download for your madden game oh
download oh colin kaepernick's on there
great you know but uh i i do i just
think i i really i really do i think
it's disrespectful where they rated him
and again i know nobody's been
disrespected maybe more in the history
of the nfl than colin kaepernick but to
disrespect guys who have been playing at
a pretty high level here a guy like josh
allen i mean what there's no way i would
take colin kaepernick over josh allen
right now that's insane
so whoever was doing those ratings needs
to go back to the the the lab and adjust
some things
can we put the graphic up again because
i think here's the reality
if you give colin kaepernick
a 75
right even if you give him a 75 tied
with teddy bridgewater behind joe burrow
jared goff josh allen et cetera kyle
murray
okay it makes sense if you see the 75 in
relation to every other quarterback yes
but but when you
just hear 75 people gonna be like oh
that's disrespectful to colin kaepernick
i feel like maybe from a political slash
pr perspective they felt like they had
to bump him up so it just doesn't sound
bad in isolation and this is a deeper
problem and i don't want to get into the
intricacies of the criticisms of the
madden game but there's a lot of i mean
the quarterbacks it you don't have to do
it on a curve
you they there can be a lot of good
quarterbacks in the madden game you can
80s and 90s but you don't have to say
they work that way that's what the
problem is right that's what it really
is because they can't call plays or have
sequencing of plays like sean payton
does in real life so therefore they have
to make drew brees better than he really
is in real life to make that offense
work like kyla murray a 77 are you
kidding me what what
come on i mean that's that's that's
crazy i mean we're talking about the the
best young quarterback in the game right
now the guy we're most excited about
everything about that he really showed
no flaws to his game he's ranked a 77
because arizona's not that good and
cliff kingsbury's offense is still
evolving and isn't good so that's how
they have to make that offense not good
they have to therefore handicap the
quarterback which you know that that's
the tough thing and that's why it's a
video game and not reality reality my
initial my initial reaction is to why
colin kaepernick was added to the game
yesterday the tuesday after labor day
weekend after the rosters had cut to 53
after the practice squads had been
formed
i and and look it very well may be that
the real reason was ea just didn't want
the backlash
or it may be a combination and from the
nfl's perspective think about it if
there's talk through august of colin
kaepernick being in this year's madden
and we hear he's going to be in 81 and
it's higher than 17 of the quarterbacks
in the in the league who are starters
uh that that puts pressure
more pressure on the teams to do
something about it right even though
yeah these aren't real scouts who are
coming up with the numbers just the fact
that he's back in the game yeah the fact
that ea is saying we view him as a
starting quarterback and even if they're
wrong they spend a hell of a lot of time
studying film and studying players and
they've got their systems and their
algorithms for coming up with ratings it
would have been harder for teams to
ignore him and run out the clock and
that's what they did back in june
there was talk that colin kaepernick was
gonna get an opportunity people had
their epiphany the colin kaepernick was
right all along and the murder of george
floyd proved what colin was saying back
in 2016 should have been paid attention
to he shouldn't have been a pariah for
doing what he did and and and again they
ran out the clock and then they needed
to let the clock continue to be at zero
before they cranked it up again
on
september the 8th and and jammed colin
kaepernick back into the game i look i
this isn't something that just happened
out of the no definitely this was
carefully planned carefully engineered
and carefully strategized to pick the
right time in the right moment to put
him back in the game whether it's
protect ea whether it's reduce the
pressure on the teams or both i think
yesterday was specifically picked
to to achieve some goal and maybe it's
multiple goals they were trying to get
because
they had to have known he was going to
be in the game when the game came out i
doubt this came up in the last week so
uh yeah i'm skeptical and i think it's
fair to be skeptical i'm skeptical about
their excuse as to why i wasn't in the
game the last time one of the things
i've been trying to find out i mean
madden 18 he unless he voluntarily and
specifically withdrew from the nfl pa
group licensing arrangement three years
ago when he was a free agent looking for
a job like other guys who are unsigned
when when the madden game comes out and
they're still available in the game
unless he specifically withdrew from the
group licensing agreement he should have
been in the game three years ago yeah
and uh i i i you know it's look it's
it's been fishy it's been sketchy and
ea's had their epiphany the problem is
none of the 32 teams have had their
epiphany and as we discussed yesterday
with peter king i feel like we're at the
point where
they've cleared the wall it's over yeah
it's not happening yeah it's done it is
it
as much as i think you know colin
kaepernick we know he's got talent to be
a starting quarterback and do all those
things
yeah between
hey of course yes the the scrutiny
whatever you want to call it the
headache of him being in the locker room
and the fact the biggest thing that he
hasn't played so long which is yeah it's
it sucks for lack of a better phrase
it's really screwed up because yeah he
was phased out by the nfl and now that
he's phased out by the nfl and we go hey
you're still good enough to be in the
nfl the nfl goes well you've been phased
out for too long now we don't want you
and
that's that's where it really stinks and
i feel for colin kaepernick that way
definitely
last point real quickly the first step
would be to put him on a practice squad
and this year you can have six guys per
team with unlimited nfl experience and
josh mccown is getting 12 grand a week
for a no-show job with the eagles where
he just needs to be in shape and
available if they need him he's not even
practicing with the team but look i i
you know we're going to have injuries to
quarterbacks and when that happens it's
next man up and it creates vacancies on
the practice squad at some point that's
where it would happen if it's going to
happen you got to get him on a practice
squad you got to get him back into shape
you got to evaluate him that way because
the time to do it was in august the fact
that august is over makes it easier for
teams to say we've got our rosters we've
got our quarterbacks we know who we're
going to use and the mere fact that he's
not on one of these initial practice
squads tells me that
it's going to take a lot of quarterback
injuries or quarterbacks with covid
before that phone call comes and if i
had to bet i'd say the phone call is not
going to come all right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports